you're watching white coming up on this
week's show Angela looks at the
technology putting crew safety first I
test out a hackable ball turning
programming into play and we've got the
best fighter game available right now
perhaps according to this week's
reviewer welcome to swipe we're at an
Innovation Centre in London this is made
by many it's a home for new tech
ventures and this week we've got some
enthusiastic children with us they'll be
helping me to throw around a computer
later on stay with us for that but first
and on a more serious note angela has
been looking at technology helping those
who risk their lives to save others
innovations in marine engineering a
dramatically changing crew safety at sea
volunteer lifeguards at the RNLI tend to
an average 23 call-outs a day around the
UK and Island they say new technology is
making it easier for them to operate
vessels when on rescue missions this is
the Shannon class lifeboat and it's the
system information management system on
this screen we've got CCTV cameras
positioned in every single space which
means in rough weather the lifeboat crew
if they have to operate the boat and
have to move around the boat can be kept
an eye on and men sure that they're kept
safe in this scream you're the plan tilt
zoom camera which enables any any
operator to look and understand exactly
what's going on around the external of
the vessel so if you're at sea and
you're alongside a rather large ship
trying to carry out a transfer the
position of the boat can be monitored
from this position the boat also has
features like shock absorbing seats and
water jets instead
propellers which allow it to operate in
shallow waters these are the Shannon
lifeboats that house all that technology
and they're manufactured here at the
all-weather lifeboat center in Paul now
each one of these costs about 2.1
million pounds to make and it has an
operational lifetime of about 25 years
but one of the other key features about
these boats is that they're designed to
inherently be self-righting so returning
to an upright position if it capsizes
new technology is also helping
lifeguards in training surveillance is a
critical part of their job and devices
like this are helping them with that eye
tracker is incorporated into glasses and
can show how rescue workers process
information how they respond to it and
whether or not that response is
appropriate one in essence records the
field of vision which is everything
that's in front of the respondent or
this case the lifeguard and then the
second camera actually picks up the eye
we use various bits of technology to
pick the IARC
and what happens basically is that those
two bits of data emerged together
so what you end up with is a video with
a crosshair on it over the top it shows
us exactly where people are looking this
technique used across sports science is
about training rescue workers to really
focus on what they are looking at future
plans to combine this technology with
other biometric data like nerve
responses and pupil dilation means a
more in-depth analysis will help reveal
differences between beginners and
lifeguards ready for more challenging
tasks Angela Barnes Sky News you're
watching zweite stay with us still to
come from here the toy teaching kids to
code but first here's a roundup of some
of this week's other tech news Apple is
in a row with the US government after
the tech giant was asked to access a
terrorist's iPhone to help the FBI CEO
Tim Cook wrote a letter to Apple
customers hitting back at the ruling
saying the company was being asked to
build a backdoor to the iPhone a British
company is hoping its prototype hydrogen
car will revolutionize
the way we build use and pay for our
vehicles the ratha has no gears and only
emits water there are just two types of
hydrogen car currently on sale in the UK
this one is set to be available in 2018
now if you tend to need a bit of help in
the kitchen maybe this can help smarty
pants has launched on crowdfunding
website IndieGoGo his teachers uses how
to cook with its temperature and weight
sensors linked to an app and tracks
nutrition the makers say it also
monitors your fitness goals and here's a
project proving popular on Kickstarter
remedy lets you turn your hand into a
musical instrument apparently you can
program notes into the sensor loaded
glove while the wristband hosts the
control center stick around for our
games review we've got the new release
from a well known series now about that
throwable computer I mentioned earlier
this is how it works with an app that
the kids have used to program a game
where you throw the ball and if you
shake it too hard it's gonna vibrate
turn red and we continue to program it
to play lots of different games yeah so
question yeah we did so we're doing
catch Buster 3 and it was really slow
Graham and it's a really fun game as
well so if it hits too hard and hits the
ground then it's gonna vibrate and we
will lose that round really is this the
kind of thing you would want at school
and yes
and more exciting
home more exciting the confuse it's
alright and you we smashed your
Kickstarter funding target with this
didn't you we did we asked for a hundred
thousand dollars and we've actually
raised two hundred and forty thousand so
now we're working on manufacturing
hackable and getting it out to our
backers well off the back of your
success debt we actually sent some
details about hackable to a tech
entrepreneur and business expert to get
her view of the products I wondered if
you wanted to have a look at what she
thought success on Kickstarter in terms
of funding and now the entire first
runner product is sold out my only
reservation about the product is how do
you ensure those children do actually
build programs at the platform and the
app the hackable have built allow it to
do I'm a little bit nervous the parents
aren't necessarily equipped with the
skills to help their children to program
and equally how do you ensure that
children don't just get halfway through
don't understand and then stop so what
do you make of that well I think she
raised some really good points on what
we've done in the design of hackable is
work with parents and kids to make sure
that parents understand the app and
understand what their kids are doing
when they work are able to use it they
create it we have and we've tested we
brought some parents along today as well
and we'll be showing them how the kids
have progressed a bit later on well
thanks for showing us hackable and guys
thank you for showing us how to play
with it so Wow that's enough fun and
games for me but not for you because
here's chris with our games review the
Far Cry series has had quite a few
iterations at this point there's been
spin-offs before there was one called
Blood Dragon that was of a neon eighties
kind of thing this is Far Cry primal
where you play as a caveman so it does
kind of change the game up a little bit
because obviously there's no guns guns
so you've got a bow and arrow and a club
and that's kind of it but the thing I
like most about it is you can tame
animal friends one of the first ones you
can tame
ow and then you get to fly around as an
owl over like an enemy encampment scout
out the enemies and fly back down but
you can't aim saber-tooth Tigers walls
nobody's going around helping you out
it's got some of the insane
over-the-top characters but I'm not a
big fan of because they're all a bit
obvious I don't know but the rest of the
gameplay is quite fun definitely worth
checking out if you enjoy profile
project cross owned - combines a ton of
different famous game developers
characters so you've got like Sega
Nintendo now because it's on the free PS
Bandai Namco Capcom all in together so
you're getting people from Street fire
and Tech and Phoenix Wright and Megaman
all in the same game and they all do
battle with each other and against the
common foe sort of a tactical RPG so
you're taking your turns and moving your
little people and stuff like that one
thing I liked about this one its
streamlined the gameplay a little bit
the first one battles could go on for
half an hour 40 minutes and you're
playing on a pourable thing you ideally
want it to be kind of quick and this
doesn't get rid of a debt like it's
still quite a difficult game okay you
can apply on a community and it kind of
works a little better Street Fighter 5
is the best fighting game available at
the moment which is a pretty bold way a
beginner review just saying it's the
best but it is it's really good it takes
all the elements of the oldest Street
BIOS and take some of the not-so-good
elements of say for which ball in a very
solid game but it's taken out a few
things and put in new gameplay mechanics
that just add a layer of depth that's
ridiculously fun it kind of rewards you
not just running in and button mashing
which is kind of standard for these sort
of games that you just sit there and
just do that like oh I win but you
actually have to sort of watch what
someone's doing jump in and out and get
tiny punches and your kicks and you try
and learn the combos and stuff like that
also if you are someone in the FG C
which is the fighting game community
this game is gonna be huge like Street
Fighter always the gold standards like
there's huge tournaments of ridiculous
money on the line
it's sort of like the football of the
fighting game community the Street
Fighter 5 is gonna be crazy in that
community and yep it's the best fighting
game available right now well that's it
for this week from this Innovation
Center I'll see you again next time
and also have a look at what else
they're working on but we'll save that
for another episode as way see using bye
bye